o
Olá pessoal meu nome é Bernardo Cândido
e em 2019 eu fui convidado a participar
de um projeto do governo federal do
governo do Brasil um projeto de
cooperação com países da África que
tinham ali um país da África Subsaariana
e esse projeto tem como objetivo
auxiliar
os produtores locais de algodão aumentar
a produtividade né E o nosso objetivo no
projeto é fornecer para eles ferramentas
não apenas técnicas e tecnológicas mas
também Treinamentos e capacitações para
que eles consigam por si só superar os
desafios que que envolvem aquele
ambiente em que eles vivem né para
conseguir aumentar a produção e
economicamente ter sucesso né E a minha
ideia de participar do projeto né a
ideia de
deu entrar nesse projeto é agregar
componente tecnológico né mim a
acadêmica eu venho trabalhando já há
algum tempo com aplicação de uso de
veículos Aéreos não tripulados
monitoramento de impactos ambientais
desde erosão erosão hídrica até a
aplicação também em áreas agrícolas
então a ideia desse projeto a
expectativa minha no início esse projeto
era colaborar com todos né com a equipe
do projeto no intuito de
auxiliá-los né então eu fui com esse
sentimento de colaborar e contribuir
Entretanto é nem sempre é a realidade se
assemelha com as expectativas nós temos
no início né e muitas vezes essa é a
realidade pode inclusive Superar as
expectativas que foi que aconteceu nesse
projeto né A primeira vez que eu pisei
no solo africano
e eu tive um sentimento muito muito
diferente né de ver o sofrimento
daquelas pessoas entretanto no olhar de
cada um eu sentia um sentimento de
esperança deles com a gente um
sentimento de que a gente poderia trazer
para eles uma boa nova
o início quando as primeiras missões
nossas no país eu tive eu confesso que
eu tive um pouco de receio eu pensei
comigo mesmo Será que eles vão ter
condições de aplicar todas essas
essas técnicas e tecnologias que nós
estamos dispostos a transmitir para eles
não pela capacidade
intelectual e cognitiva deles nada nada
disso mais nem no sentido de que é pela
por todas as adversidades que eles vivem
vender em Sião lá né eu fiquei pensando
será que eles vão conseguir colocar em
prática tudo isso
mas não demora muito tempo para eu
sentir e a força de superação daquelas
pessoas a força de superação perante
Todas aquelas dificuldades aquele todo
aquele sofrimento que eu via naquele
momento é com eu sentia vivendo e
Vencendo com eles lá né e com pouco
tempo eu consegui perceber que eles têm
uma força de eu consegui não apenas não
reclamar das das adversidades que eles
tavam vivenciando no momento mas também
de darem as mãos e juntos Consegui
superar aquelas adversidades e eu pensei
muito durante muito tempo né porque
quando a gente nós chegávamos nas Vilas
para fazer os trabalhos diariamente
e nós éramos recebidos com sorrisos e
com um olhar de esperança por eles e eu
fiquei pensando refletindo durante muito
tempo
E como que pessoas que têm condições tão
vulneráveis tô tão vulneráveis como eles
conseguem ainda manter uma alegria no
semblante
e isso foi algo que me chamou muita
atenção naquele momento e eu fiquei
refletindo muito sobre isso eles tinham
todas as justificativas do mundo para
reclamar o tempo todo desde a hora de
acordar até o sol se pôr entretanto que
eles faziam o que eles fazem até hoje é
se unir darem as mãos para porque só
assim eles conseguem superar os desafios
e o filho comecei a trazer isso para mim
Quantas vezes a gente reclama dia sim
outro dia também de coisas corriqueiras
do dia-a-dia e nos esquecemos do
Essencial né que nós temos condição sim
de superar todas essas adversidades
então isso foi algo que me chamou muita
atenção
chegar numa aldeia aonde
aproximadamente Vinte por cento das
crianças não sobrevivem até os cinco
anos de idade e ser recebido com um
olhar de esperança
e é ao que me chamou muita atenção isso
eu fiquei durante muito tempo pensando
sobre isso e essas Vilas que o projeto
está inserido
podem não ter muitas Posses Mas eles têm
uma riqueza imensurável que a terem uns
aos outros
é isso através dessa união entre eles e
dessa cooperação entre eles e é que eles
conseguem
é realmente vencer aquelas dificuldades
bom então isso foi ao que eu trouxe
comigo
e nas primeiras vezes que nós tivemos
alguns projetos lá né de capacitações eu
não esqueço quando eu fui dar um curso
de mapeamento aéreo que é um assunto que
demanda é bastante concentração porque
não é um assunto muito trivial para eles
e eu tenho certeza de que aquela turma
que eu tive naquele momento foi até hoje
a turma mais dedicada que eu pude ter
contato
é porque eu eu senti um olho com os
olhos de cada um que eles não queriam
desperdiçar aquela preciosa oportunidade
de aprender é de aprendizado
é de quantos de nós muitas vezes
esperamos uma segunda chance e eu olhei
no olhando nos olhos deles em todas as
vezes que eu vou lá eu percebo que eles
tratam cada oportunidade como se fosse
única
bom então toda essa todo esse contexto
me fez refletir que apesar de estarmos
vivendo todos todos nós toda a
humanidade
sob o mesmo céu só A fraternidade
e tem poder
além de trazer para todas as pessoas
daquele local onde eles vão de eles
vivem né
uma dignidade uma ascensão social e uma
capacidade de conseguir superar todas as
dificuldades e dessa forma
cada um de nós temos condições de ser
fraternos não precisa de fazermos parte
de um projeto como esse um projeto
internacional Todos nós temos condição
de dentro do nosso próprio círculo de
amizade nosso próprio círculo social de
fazer algo
a fazer algo e auxiliar nessa nesse esse
trabalho de
crescimento e de evolução como todos nós
como um
E não esqueça de uma palavra que foi
medida por um cidadão local um amigo que
eu fiz
aonde quando acendemos movimento para
levar doações para as brasileiras e para
as aldeias né aonde projeto está
instalado
e eu lembro que eu perguntei para que eu
disse para ele né
Nós trouxemos poucas doações ele disse
Bernardo nada aqui é pouco
é muito obrigada